bonsoir le journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour faire le tour de l'actualité
locale bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
dans cette édition du mardi 23 février
voici les titres la venue ce matin de
marc guillaume dans les yvelines le
préfet de la région ile de france s'est
rendue au moulin de saint cyr l'école et
à l'école nationale supérieure de
l'architecturé de versailles et vivent
dans le cadre du plan france relance de
100 milliards d'euros lancée par le
gouvernement
les élections la présidence de la
fédération française de cyclisme
approche l'assemblée générale doit se
tenir samedi prochain au siège de
l'instance à montigny le bretonneux ait
deux candidats michel callot président
sortant et l'ancien sélectionneur
cyrille guimard scrutin au sein d'une
fédération frappé de plein fouet par la
crise sanitaire nous en parlons avec nos
invités représentants de clubs locaux
yvelinois et puis l'information a été
révélée hier les daft punk se séparent
après 28 ans de carrière l'occasion de
revenir sur cette rumeur folle celle de
la prétendue origines versaillais studio
pionnier de la french touch une fac news
que nous décortiquons à la fin de cette
édition et nous prendrons également un
peu de hauteur dans ce journal direction
les arbres pour un parcours
d'accrobranche à saint germain en laye
le préfet de la région ile de france est
donc rendu ce matin à saint cyr l'école
puis aversa et marc guillaume a visité
deux projets soutenus dans le cadre du
plan france relance du gouvernement
le reportage de nicolas landry et de
patrick jacques de dixmude c'est
l'illustration de l'engagement de l'état
pour la restauration du patrimoine des
investissements du plan france relance
engagés dans deux projets l'aménagement
autour du moulin de saint cyr l'école
après sa destruction et la rénovation de
l'école nationale de l'architecturé
versailles
l'objet du double déplacement du préfet
de région d'île de france marc guillaume
skis et comme en revanche aux deux sites
c'est l'impact du plan de relance
arriver à mobiliser d'un côté avec le
conseil régional conseil départemental
de l'intercommunalité 9 millions d'euros
pour faire ses travaux sur cet ancien
moulin ancienne minoterie
mais ici dégagé près de 30 millions
d'euros pour arriver à moderniser
l'école d'architecturé la démolition du
moulin de saint cyr l'école va permettre
la construction d'un parking
un aménagement à proximité de l'allée
royale de villepreux le nom d'un arrêt
sur la future ligne 13 du tramway entre
saint germain en laye et saint cyr
l'école
tout cela alors que les épreuves
équestres des jeux olympiques de paris
en 2024 se tiendront ici les jeux seront
lancés fait que
et nous on se retrouve aujourd'hui
devant la grille et l'allée qui est
derrière nous qui est en train d'être
nallet qui prolongeait le tapis vert et
le grand canal du parc du château de
versailles sur 4 kilomètres à travers la
plaine de versailles
là il s'agit d'en replanter 800 mètres
entre la sortie du parc et l'autoroute
a12
on a déjà replanté 140 hommes on va
encore en planter 300 lits l'automne
prochain et le reste sera planté l'année
suivante
du côté de l'école nationale supérieure
de l'architecturé en face du château de
versailles la toiture et les huisseries
vont faire peau neuve
trois tranches de travaux menés en même
temps jusqu'en 2022
les huisseries sont en très mauvais état
ils n'ont pas été reprises depuis très
très longtemps et
les il ya beaucoup de fuites de fuites
dans les toitures beaucoup de chez nos
bouchers du aura également dans ce
projet une partie de rénovation
énergétique qui nous permettra de faire
des économies très substantiel en
complément de cette restauration l'école
recherchent des mécènes privés pour
restaurer la façade de l'établissement
dans l'actualité cette action anti
gaspillage et solidaire lancée par
poissy est aujourd'hui une fois par
semaine la ville va remettre au 147
étudiants de la résidence geneviève
rousset des denrées alimentaires
elles proviennent des écoles de la
commune il s'agit de produits qui n'ont
pas été utilisés pour les goûters des
jeunes pisciacais et des fruits des
biscuits des jus en briques du lait et
des yaourts à poissy les entreprises
elior et pro et compagnie qui a fourni
un frigo se sont jointes à cette
mobilisation qui aura lieu chaque mardi
sur place on écoute ses propos
recueillis par astrid bergère le fait de
leur apporter des denrées alimentaires
non périssables avec un partenaire de la
ville de poissy qui ignore donc il
provient des des repas et des goûters
dans nos écoles dans nos écoles
élémentaires et nos écoles primaires va
dans le bon sens cette opération va
durer jusqu'aux vacances scolaires de
juillet d'été et si ces effectifs si ça
porte ses fruits si on a encore des
denrées et tout se passe bien on
remettra en place pour l'année scolaire
prochaine
et voilà tant qu'on pourra de façon à
aider les étudiants parce
qu'effectivement l'argent qui ne met pas
dans la nourriture et b peuvent le
mettre dans leur loyer dans leurs études
et peut-être les loisirs aussi parce que
ils ont besoin de vivre avec la crise
sanitaire la précarité s'est creusée
chez les étudiants près de 20% d'entre
eux vivraient aujourd'hui sous le seuil
de pauvreté
on ouvre une page sports à présent dans
ce journal l'assemblée générale de la
fédération française de cyclisme sera
organisée ce samedi 27 février au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines au programme l'élection du
président pour les quatre prochaines
années michael et demi d'euros est avec
mon plateau bonsoir vend sa journaliste
sport de la rédaction de tv 78 qui se
présentera pour cette élection alors le
cyclisme français va devoir trancher
entre deux hommes deux personnalités à
michel callot et cyrille guimard on va
commencer par le premier michel callot
54 ans est en poste depuis le 11 mars
2017 il a pris la suite de david
lappartient parti à l'union cycliste
internationale cci sept ans un coureur
de première catégorie amateur sera le
grand favori de ce rendez-vous il
briguera donc un second mandat de quatre
ans on écoute
nous l'avons rencontré le week-end
dernier sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines lorsque quatre ans
pour pour animer une fédération la
taille la fédération française de
cyclisme est vraiment pouvoir dérouler
un projet c'est pour donc j'ai toujours
eu dans l'idée de plutôt m'orienter vers
deux mandats et puis il était survenu
quand même sept années 2020 et la crise
sanitaire qui a bloqué bon nombre de
projets et c'est aussi une frustration
de ne pas pouvoir les
les mener à leur terme
sans faire un deuxième mandat ce serait
effectivement dommage alors son
programme tourne autour de l'aide envers
des clubs cyclistes dans l'après crise
et également les deux olympiades tokyo
et paris des rendez vous il faudra
ramener des médailles hrigory il sera
donc opposé à cyrille guimard alors
cyrille guimard un vrai personnage celui
que l'on surnomme le druide à 74 ans
c'est un ancien coureur cycliste
français avec plusieurs tours de france
à son actif il était très doué dans les
sprints il a également gagné sept tours
de france en tant que directeur sportif
avec les équipes gitane et renault dans
les années 70 et 80 avec des bernard
hinault et laurent fignon est
aujourd'hui commentateur sportif pour
ces élections il prône notamment une
nouvelle politique de formation de haut
niveau il voudrait notamment détecter
les champions a très tôt dès 8 ans on
écoute sa vision sur la formation tout
neuf formations tout notre tout notre
développement dans les quatre jeunes
mâles pour le remettre en cause
vous prenez le cyclo cross on est à la
rue vous prenez la piste on est à la rue
y'a que le vtt où on surnage un petit
peu donc quand on regarde ça et que vous
avez les jeux olympiques en 2024
je crois qu'à un moment il faut essayer
de se poser les bonnes questions
on ne détient pas la vérité bien sûr
mais il faut se poser les bonnes
questions qu'est ce qu'on fait pour que
nous aussi on est des champions ont même
âge les autres pays et ces élections
s'annoncent particulièrement mouvementée
cyrille guimard l association prend un
marron annoncés ces dernières heures
qu'ils avaient déposé des recours auprès
du cnosf afin de dénoncer des
irrégularités dans ces has élections
pour l'heure l'élection de ce samedi
n'est pas remise en cause a se déroulera
bien au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
merci michael pour ces précisions et
pour parler de ce sujet justement avec
nous à présent deux invités en plateau
daniel gagne bonsoir bonsoir président
de la section compétition du vélo club
de montigny le bretonneux le décès mb en
visioconférence christophe touzeau
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes vous membre du
bureau du vélo-club d'elancourt saint
quentin en yvelines le vc au sky à steam
vous sert déjà un premier tour de parole
on va commencer avec vous daniel gagne
on imagine que c'est une élection que
vous suivez
avec attention ben je veux plus que la
suivre puisque je serai un des cinq
représentantes d'ile-de-france pour
voter d'accord et pour vous christophe
touzeau on imagine aussi que ces suivis
avec attention du côté du club du
vaisseau sky l'attention surtout que
nous on vient d'organiser ce week-end
est bon grâce à la ffc on a plus sortir
une course pendant une bonne journée
semaine de préparation
vous organisez effectivement les
championnats de france de cyclo-cross on
va y revenir dans cette interview sans
nous dire pour qui va votre préférence
là n'est pas la question quels sont à
votre avis les enjeux sur le prochain
mandat de quoi faut-il parler pour ce
prochain mandat à la fédération
française de cyclisme
déjà déjà quand j'ai le calot a pris la
présidence il y avait une situation
financière catastrophique donc déjà eu
beaucoup de beaucoup de mal à redresser
la barre aujourd'hui ils ont une
situation qui est enviable disons il n'y
a pas de souci maintenant il faut qu'ils
ont un peu de moyens il faut qu'ils
développent
leurs idées au niveau des sportifs chose
qu'ils n'ont pas en cours tentent votre
avis christophe touzeau peut-être sur
des sujets aussi qui concerne
directement les club yvelinois
c'est à dire qu'il vient d'être élu à 4
ans à 2017
c'est ça avec une année 2020 très
particulière 2021 qui s'annonce pas bien
non plus donc les projets qu'il avait
mené je pense que sont très difficiles
abonnés en ce moment est bon si une
deuxième réflexion pour lui une bonne
continuité dans ce qu'il a commencé
depuis quatre ans justement il dit une
année 2020 particulière où la fédération
française de cyclisme à l'image aussi un
des autres disciplines a été frappé de
plein fouet par cette crise sanitaire
huit mille huit cents licenciés en moins
soit une baisse de 7 5% sur l'année
est ce que cette perte s'est aussi
ressentie dans votre club christophe
touzeau
oui bien sûr on a perdu un peu de
coureurs au sein du club
comme tous les clubs comme tous les
sports d'ailleurs de toute façon dans
toutes disciplines confondues l'année
2020 les inscriptions 2021 tout le monde
est un peu en attente
je pense que 2021 compliqué 2022 en
espérant que ça se relancer les
inscriptions reviennent nouveau les gens
puissent se faire plaisir sur les
entraînements aussi bien sur les courses
on a combien licencié à peu près sûr le
vc au sky on doit être à peu près à 81,5
très bien et vous savez combien combien
vous avez perdu licenciés justement
j'aurais pas les chiffres exacts mais on
en installe et on a dû perdre une
dizaine de licenciés ils ne sont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas renouvelé il je pense
qu'ils n'ont même pas retrouvé le dos au
club remplit donc c'est vraiment une
perte sèche situation similaire aussi du
côté du vcmb c'est similaire bon l'année
dernière on était 94
grosso modo on perd chaque année à peu
près 25 licenciés qui renouvelle pas et
on a à peu près 25 à 30 noeuds or cette
année on a eu quinze nouveaux pour 30
qui n'ont pas renouvelé et sur ce dont
on est sûr qu'ils vont reprendre une
licence j'en ai encore ben dit attendre
d'accord donc un contexte où l'a compris
forcément compliqué on est d'ailleurs
passé d'un premier confinement ou
finalement rien n'était possible en
terme
entraînement à des entraînements qui ont
repris progressivement comment vous êtes
vous adapté justement à la crise
sanitaire pour permettre une continuité
de vos activités daniel gagne c'est
compliqué parce que bon au niveau des
jeunes en a pas de problème on n'a pas
de problème parce qu'on n'a pas de
limitation au niveau des jeunes par
contre au niveau des adultes là c'est
compliqué j'ai dès dimanche matin où je
suis obligé de faire quatre groupes
différents et couvrir quatre groupes
différents
ça me pose un problème on va parler dans
un instant et championnats de france de
cyclo cross mais est-ce que les
compétitions sont à l'arrêt du coup
aussi pour un pour le moment normalement
ils doivent elles doivent démarrer le
1er mars
on fait comme si mais je doute qu'ils
aient lieu alors il ya des courses qui
est où les engagements se sont ouverts
aujourd'hui au 7 mars par exemple à
satory mais ça m'étonnerait qu'elle ait
lieu par exemple on ne sait pas on
attend la réponse de la mairie puisque
là ça dépend en priorité de la mairie
mais nous c'est dernier dimanche de mars
donc on a un peu plus de temps mais je
serais étonné que les compétitions
reprennent avant le mois d'avril on est
toujours des incertitudes on a compris
alors justement pour lever ces escales
le week-end dernier le club a co
organisé avec la ffc
les championnats de france de
cyclo-cross pour les catégories cadets
juniors et masters c'était à huis clos
en le précise à lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines avec une jauge
de 500 personnes jour sur cet événement
le bilan que vous dressez les plutôt
positif pour nous il est plutôt positif
une course qu'on en fait et ça nous a
sollicités thierry fabre est à peu près
cinq semaines on s'est allié avec
d'autres clubs comme les baisser les
mureaux il devait serait trop pour
pouvoir organiser ou le mieux cette
organisation et et avoir quelque chose
de bien faire hermétique et ne pas y
avoir les problèmes qu'on nous mais avec
la crise sanitaire
ça s'est très bien déroulé on a quand
même réussi à avoir cinq cent cinquante
coureurs répartis sur toute la journée
donc avec les mesures qui en valait en
avant
tout bouclé pour éviter d'avoir les
spectateurs qui sont certes fait
malheureusement juste le personnel qui
en avait besoin et tout s'est passé
super bien et là effet très ravi d'avoir
pu sauver pour les jeunes au moins un
championnat de france surtout pour les
cadets les juniors et bien sûr aussi
pour les masters disent que c'est la
preuve finalement que en s'organisant en
préconisant voilà des mesures barrières
aussi sur sur ces compétitions on peut
organiser des événements avec quand même
ces conditions barrières tout à faire le
fait d'être en extérieur déjà avant sa
pause bêtement un problème que la paire
l'intérieur et le loup clubs sont
capables je parle pour des gros clubs ça
compte s'entourer d'autres clubs
capables d'organiser des ddd des courses
avec un tout la crise tout ce qui est
horriblement sanitaire autour et de
protéger au mieux les coureurs et
malheureusement ils seront tous à huis
clos c'est sûr mais au moins qui puisse
accrocher un dossard pour se faire
plaisir et roma suivre la suite des
événements avec attention voire ci a
peut-être d'autres compétitions
pourraient être organisées à l'avenir
merci à vous deux daniel gagne en
plateau je rappelle président de la
section compétition au vélo club de
montigny le bretonneux et ma fille
également à christophe touzeau qui
étaient avec nous par vidéoconférence
membres du bureau du vélo-club
d'elancourt saint quentin en yvelines
en cette période de vacances scolaires
il fallait trouver des activités en
extérieur pour occuper les enfants à
saint germain en laye par exemple le
parc d'accrobranche a rouvert depuis la
mi-février direction la cime des arbres
avec célia gars de 100 go et patrick
jacques de dixmude avec un beau soleil
samedi 20 février la crau quand des
saint germain en laye a fait carton
plein presque toutes les places étaient
réservées la veille c'est-à-dire plus de
207 parcours d'accrobranche et sont
disponibles il y en a pour tous les
goûts en fait quand vous venez ici on
vous répartis sur les parcours en
fonction de votre taille et de votre
personnalité si vous êtes plutôt
craintif plutôt à l'aise ou plutôt
téméraire
comme on dit on vous êtes accompagné du
début jusqu'à la fin
dans le choix des parcours dans
l'initiation sur les parcours
d'entraînement et dans les différentes
activités qu'on propose ici
le parc est récent il a été ouvert en
l'accrobranche n'est pas la seule
activité possible sur le site
on essaye de s'inscrire dans une
démarche éco responsable donc on propose
des courses d'orientation des jeux sur
le thème de la nature anniversaire team
building et stages qui peuvent durer de
deux jours à une semaine
le parc est accessible à tous ses
activités en extérieur permettent de se
retrouver entre amis ou en famille vu
que les restos sont fermées et les bars
on ferme et on s'est dit que c'était la
seule activité possible à faire un plein
air on voulait réserver en fait
finalement ce matin mais c'était au
complet donc on s'est dit qu'on
passerait tout simplement sur site
directement voir s'il y avait de la
place au final pas au final on est on
est bien tombé on a l'impression d'être
libre dans l'ailleurs chose qu'on n'est
pas sur terre aujourd'hui donc le fait
d'être dans l'herbe assez bien on s'en
libérer surtout trouver actuellement
donc ça fait du bien au mental
il parcourra plus tôt cette semaine à 10
heures pour accueillir davantage de
clients et pour refermer ce journal
j'accueille eléonore sinoquet de la
rédaction de tv 78 bon soir en ça avec
vous on va parler musique des rumeurs il
y en a eu pendant les 28 ans de carrière
de daft punk mais cette fois ci la noce
est bien réel le groupe français de
musique électronique le plus célèbre au
monde a annoncé sa séparation hier lundi
alors parmi les rumeurs les plus
célèbres celle d'un duo casqué qui
viendrait de versailles pour les daft
punk
est ce réellement le cas et je ne rends
pas du tout grigori les daft punk ne
sont malheureusement pas originaire de
versailles on aurait pourtant été get
lucky qu'ils soient chinois
[Musique]
et comme ils sont évidemment inimitable
le duo a annoncé sa séparation en grande
pompe il a publié une vidéo sur sa
chaîne youtube
ces images titré épilogue montre l'un
des deux hommes robot se faisant sauter
sous les yeux de l'autre de leur vrai
nom thomas bang bang alter pardon en 46
ans et guy manuel de homem christo 47
ans sont vous l'avez rappelé gregori
connu run the world d'évoquer ce sont
même les français les plus connus du
monde en musique électronique et donc
vous le confirme et lui ne sont pas de
chez nous non cette rumeur alors à
coller à la peau pendant des années et
l'on pouvait facilement en vrai dire se
faire duper d'abord par wikipedia moteur
de recherche où tout le monde peut se
créer une fiche d'information alors pas
sur la fiche des daft punk mais sur
celle du lycée hoche à versailles
il y figurait comme anciens élèves mais
ce n'est pas du tout le cas
en revanche doivent pas me connais
certains monde du groupe français
phoenix par exemple qui eux ont bien
étudié au lycée hoche
ils font d'ailleurs tous partie du
courant musical la french touch avec le
groupe air également originaire de
versailles est d'ailleurs dans une
interview au magazine télérama en 2013
thomas bangalter déclarait je cite et
puisqu'on parle de wikipédia si vous
pouviez préciser que nous ne sommes
absolument pas de versailles versailles
j'ai dû y mettre les pieds quatre fois
dans ma mission
ensuite et le nan c'est aussi une
histoire de localisation d'entreprise
qui a pu tromper son monde un petit peu
tout à fait le dio casque et posséderait
deux entreprises daft musique et daft
tracks et ils sont situés je vous le
donne en mille
rue de versailles sauf que cette rue
elle est située la marne la coquette
dans les hauts-de-seine en france qui
pourrait une nouvelle fois trompé bien
que tout de même très alambiquées le
réalisateur du clip de leur fameuse
chanson run the world qu'on a entendu
juste à l'instant michel gondry est
lui-même originaire de versailles dont
grégory one more time non daft punk
n'est pas originaire de versailles merci
à l'honneur pour cette fin de journal en
musique s'il n'y avait qu'une chose une
dernière chose à dire parce que toutes
les bonnes choses ont une fin on leur
souhaite pour leurs futurs projets voilà
c'est en musique que l'on referme ce
journal merci à eléonore merci de votre
fidélité dans un instant le 7-8 culture
présentée par justine brasier quant au
journal de la rédaction de revient est
dès demain mercredi pour une nouvelle
édition et vous retrouverez pour la
suite de la semaine à la présentation
eléonore sinoquet belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]